The official Dark Souls' Design Works books
are incredible, with interviews and concept
art that give wonderful insight into the development
process.
But the thing I want to talk to you about
today, isn't in the Dark Souls design works.
Specifically, it was left out.
Archived on Resetera, are these fantastic
images, allegedly drawn by an artist named
Jocus Wang.
There's a dark hellscape, where your eyes
are drawn towards a bleeding sun..There's
art that looks like it might have inspired
Cainhurst library, from Bloodborne..There's
a gothic courtyard..that one commenter points
out merges the Berlin Cathedral, and the Louvre..there
are statues that might once have been graceful,
but have become horrifically worn..There's
concept art of Archdragon Peak.. a tired settlement,
and my personal favourite, a sort of abandoned
sewer area, with just enough light filtering
through to nourish gentle growths of moss.
I love the verticality here..and the way the
artist uses light to draw you into every little
nook..it's masterful.
Now, that first image should be familiar to
anyone who saw the Dark Souls 3 leaks published
all the way back in 2015.
This famous screenshot showed that same bleeding
sun, and a world reduced to a hellish ruin.
I remember, those leaks were especially shitty
for From Software back then, because they
were clearly outdated and misleading..but
looking back now, along with the artwork,
these feel more like lost treasures to me
- and they do wonders for the intrigue behind
these games.
I'll of course take this down if From Soft
or Jocus request it, but we get precious little
insight into the development process, and
it's fun to imagine the game that could have
been.
Of course, if you want some official insight
into these games, go and buy the official
It's no secret that when you kill Ornstein
first in Dark Souls 1, Smough grows larger.
And when you kill Smough first, Ornstein grows
larger.
Or..does he?
Recently, Zullie revealed a clever camera
trick in this scene - whereby Ornstein actually
stays the same size, while Smough's body,
and the arena, shrinks instead.
Considering there isn't a functional size
scaling value for character models in this
game, Zullie speculates that this would have
been far easier for them to implement.
These Secrets videos have become, first and
foremost, a way to point you towards other
creators and creations that can enrich your
appreciation of the Souls series..so please,
go and click all the links in the description,
before you leave.
And lately, Zullie the Witch has been absolutely
killing it.
The algorithm has finally taken a liking to
her short, entertaining videos..and I feel
like it all started with this one.
As you know, if you kill Ornstein first, you
get super smough.
If you kill smough first, you get super ornstein.
But..
"What happens if you kill Ornstein and Smough
at the same time"?
By using an AOE attack to force a tie..the
winner is..Smough.
That's because the event is tied to whichever
animation ends first, and Smough has a faster
death animation.
But what happens if you kill Ornstein first,
then Smough quickly after, to line up their
animations?
Well..you can't.
From Software thought of this, and added immortality
to the other character once their partner
dies.
Interestingly, if animation length is removed
as a factor, and both their HP are set to
0..then there is code that enables Ornstein
as the winner, every time.
Luckily, this isn't possible in regular gameplay..because
it also softlocks the fight.
Another thing I found fascinating is how they
workaround boss health bar issues in some
fights.
In fights like the four kings, or the deacons,
there's actually another member hidden off-screen.
It's their health bar you see at the bottom
of your screen, and they take damage on behalf
of all the other members you hit.
This also goes for the Gael boss fight, where
second phase Gael waits in this structure
in the distance.
When phase two starts, during the cutscene,
this damaged second phase teleports down,
and the fight continues.
From Software tend to remove a lot of cut
content from their games these days, but this
wolf snuck through on a PS4 patch for Dark
Souls 3.
It bears resemblance to the Old Wolf of Farron
covenant model, down to the same little bronze
bracelet.
Once, it seems, this was planned to be a part
of the Abyss Watchers boss fight.
Here, in a cutscene found by micb123 and uploaded
by Dropoff, we see the wolf appear as a part
of the phase 2 revival cutscene.
Here's a hot take: but I'm not sure I want
another wolf fight in the Souls series!
So I'm..pretty glad this was changed.
We've talked before about how there are grabs
you can escape in Dark Souls 1 by pressing
R1 and L1, but for many years, such a thing
was rumoured to be a glitch.
Turns out, it has its own dedicated system.
In this video, Zullie showcases how grabs
technically have their own hp.
Each escapable grab has 25hp, and each press
of R1 or L1 reduces the hp by 1.
Get it to 0, and your character performs the
escape throw animation.
Having the hp of the grab makes your button
mashing feel so much more meaningful, and
I'm kind of surprised they didn't add a sort
of status meter for it, in-game.
In a recent Demon's Souls Prepare to Cry,
we talked about Boletaria's proclivity for
slaves, and how important they were to their
wars, and greater society.
Turns out, slaves are more entrenched in the
game than I thought.
As you head up to fight Allant, the final
boss, take a look through the walls of the
elevator.
Hidden within the mechanism, are two slave
soldiers, working tirelessly to bring visitors
up to their master.
Moving into Demon's Souls - everyone knows
that the manta rays detach from the storm
king to start attacking you..but did you know
that the projectiles they shoot are..also,
actually smaller rays?
In the remake, they are, at least.
In the original, they were simple javelins.
I guess Bluepoint wanted to give you another
excuse to use their photo mode.
Recently, a fantastic article was posted to
the Playstation blog, detailing the process
behind capturing the incredible animations
of the Demon's Souls remake.
While the cadence of animations and movement
hasn't changed, the animations themselves
are updated..every single one of them.
"Performed too quickly, the movements would
lack clear arcs and silhouettes.
Performed too slowly, they might lose their
weight and inertia".
The article is a great read, explaining how
and why this project was difficult, even for
someone with 20 years of mo cap experience.
Most striking in the Remake are the brutal,
complex ripostes and backstabs - all of which
have different animations depending on the
weapon you use, and how many hands you carry
it with.
This game is a technical marvel, and a part
of me wishes From Software had a bit of that
Bluepoint polish in them.
Don't get me wrong, From Software's current
game development cycle IS super efficient
and they pump out quality games way faster
than most studios, but with Elden Ring looking
a lot like Dark Souls 3, their game appearance
IS starting to age a little, and I wonder
when we might see a visual leap forward from
them.
I'm not saying it has to happen now, but sooner
or later, something is going to give.
Moving on to Sekiro - we've talked about the
Gyoubu skip before, and even the Blazing bull
skip after that.
But what if you perform these glitches during
the Gauntlets of Strength?
One twitter user did just that (@full_metalmoron)
and shared it with me, revealing a world that
renders in in a strange way.
You should try it, and see what oddities you
can find.
The best place to visit, by far, is the silvergrass
field, which shows a lightning storm during
day, with surreal reflections and lighting.
You've all seen..or heard, the Sentries in
Sekiro..who hammer a metal pan with a metal
rod.
But did you know..they can actually attack
you?
Stand in melee range, and parry them four
times, and you'll be able to perform a fairly
unique riposte to kill them.
I learned about this from Ongbal, a Sekiro
master who uploads stunning clips of him flawlessly
killing bosses in this game.
Not only are there no errors in his clips,
but he weaves interesting combos into his
fights whenever possible, leading to some
incredibly quick takedowns.
For someone like me, who adores Sekiro's combat,
they're well worth a sub.
Now..Sekiro's combat is good and all..but
this..THIS is gameplay.
Poison rolling.
Researched by Limit Breakers a few months
ago, we learned that the Hunter's roll inherits
the effects of poison gems attached to the
right hand weapon.
This comes in two flavours - slow poison,
which builds up then drains hp over time,
and rapid poison, which builds up and deals
damage all at once.
Relative to slow, rapid is a way better option..and
can even be used against some bosses with
big HP pools, to good effect.
But relative to actually..you know, hitting
enemies..or actually using good gems..no.
Rolling poison isn't that great.
You can use the hunter's bone to speed up
the process, but many bosses have 999 poison
resistance anyway, making it a pointless endeavor.
The one thing it is good for is entertaining
challenge runs..so make sure you check out
YMFAH's "pacifist run".
You'll learn a ton more secrets from him in
that one (gascoigne disappear)
Limit Breakers put out another video recently
showing off the "Bow Bash" of Demon's Souls,
something that hasn't really been showcased
on YouTube before.
It has a strange input, requiring you to face
away from your opponent before snapping in
the opposite direction, and pressing R2.
Damage is modified by which bow you use, and
how upgraded it is..but I'll leave it to Limit
to teach you the specifics.
One of the best things about the Remake is
that all of this jank was left in this super
modern ps5 title.
There were some things in this game I never
thought we'd see..and Vicar Amelia's face
before she transforms, was one of them.
Her side profile definitely gives a younger,
and prettier impression to my imagination..than
the reality.
Luckily, Bloodborne has been explored a ton
in recent years thanks to new tools and talented
modders like LanceMcDonald..though perhaps
some things are better left unseen.
Lance also has a video showing off a never-before-seen
cutscene from the Wet Nurse boss, so go and
check out his channel for that.
Last, with a fantastic video idea, is Illusorywall,
who got AI to generate a real-life cast of
Dark Souls, based on their in-game models.
Some of this stuff is absolutely stunning..some
is horrifying..but all of it almost makes
me want a film based on these games.
I mean..it'd be a nightmare trying to write
a movie script for the Souls series, but as
IllusoryWall notes in the video, a lot of
these faces already bear resemblance to real-life
actors.
Here's one last crazy secret..your middle
mouse button can be used to open links in
new tabs, and that's exactly what you should
do for every link in the description.
Including Soul Arts!
The campaign is literally about to end, so
become a backer, if you want to join us on
this journey to produce something really special.
Thank you for watching.
Hopefully we get some Elden Ring news soon.
I'll see you in the next one.